I had to describe my style in three
words I would say sporadic fearless and
carefree if I was only allowed to wear
one item for the rest of my entire life
it would have to be pair of underwear
they had to be tight like maybe some
comic lines not total tighty whiteys but
like some underwear and then I could
play basketball in them I could walk
around and then like I'd become to walk
and go swimming in them if it was
allowed I'd be totally comfortable
walking down the streets in underwear
there's a lot of people who I look up to
it might be because I'm an actor I want
to look like different people all the
time I look back in the 50s and look at
the way Frank Sinatra used to dress or
like classic pictures of Marlon Brando
at the Oscars and I'm like wow they
looked so cool but then they're also
like nowadays like I look at the way
that some rapper is dressed I'm like
damn that's so cool like leather pants
ends cool hats and I feel like I look up
to a lot of people if I had to name the
most stylish woman on the whole planet
it would probably be my mother I love
your mom
you